[Music]  james  fate  draws us back together  now your enemy's my enemy  how did that happen  well you live long enough  harder to tell the good from bad  villains from heroes these days  we used to be able to get into a room  with the enemy  now they're just floating in the ether  she still loves you did you know that  what is it  is she one of them  i don't know her at all  when her secret finds its way out  it'll be the death of you  transformed  we both eradicate people  to make the world a better place  i just want to be a little  tidier  i met your new double oh  she's a disarming young woman  you've never flown one of these things  before  nope  come on bond where the hell are you  if we don't do this  there will be nothing left to say  when you're ready  you're late  can i just have one nice evening please  before the world explodes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you